déficit de suministros en europa la
guerra en ucrania empieza a pasar
factura a los agricultores cientos de
vacas corren el riesgo de ser
sacrificadas debido a la falta de comida
actualmente veamos problema actualmente
tenemos problemas con la compra de
alimento concentrado para los animales
sobre todo también hay un problema con
el transporte y por lo tanto la
imposibilidad de tener suministros a
tiempo hay transporte wind ya la
imposible así que esto es lo que estamos
sufriendo y pagando mucho hoy en día en
lo que hoy es confiamos y fallamos mucho
ucrania es uno de los grandes
exportadores de alimento para animales
cuyas existencias están disminuyendo
rápidamente en el sur de europa en
grecia la situación es similar
se ha vuelto insoportable no podemos
trabajar nuestros campos no podemos
cultivar no podemos poner gasolina en
nuestros vehículos y tampoco comprar
semillas y fertilizantes y alemania ya
había advertido sobre la crisis en jets
efe tuits más civilizados fellow del
software steve habrá una escasez masiva
de suministros y será grave porque
ucrania ya no podrá suministrar granos y
otros productos a países como áfrica
la realidad será que la gente se verá
amenazada por el hambre aún más y esto
aumenta el peligro de nuevos conflictos
pero también de narrativas erróneas y
beat of fighters negativa
ucrania exporta el 11 6% de trigo y el
16,4 por ciento del maíz del mundo rusia
por su parte es un gran productor de
nutrientes de los cultivos y del suelo
además es líder en la exportación de
fertilizantes con un 13 por ciento de la
producción mundial la agencia
alimentaria de las naciones unidas dijo
la semana pasada que los precios
internacionales de los alimentos y la
comida para animales podrían aumentar
hasta un 20 por ciento